there have been claims that the cost of
the cheapest food on the market is
rising proportionally faster than other
things making it even tougher for those
really struggling well the office for
national statistics have had a closer
look to ask if that's true have a look
at this this is a broad overview of what
they found that blue line at the top
there that shows the rate of price rises
for all food and soft drinks that are
usually used when calculating inflation
but remember that covers a huge range of
things including expensive items like
steak and seafood things that people
really struggling are probably unlikely
to be buying so they've also had a look
at a more specific group of products
that's the red line it essentially shows
price increases of the cheapest versions
of 30 real everyday staples and look as
you can see the two actually rose in
quite similar stead with each other
budget items by six percent overall six
point seven percent in essence it shows
cost rises are just as bad for the
cheaper products but not worse there's a
real discrepancy between items too here
are just 10 of the 30 things that were
surveyed have a look you can see big
rises for some things some things fell
away albeit fewer things there are
actually a total of 10 budget items that
rose by over 10 which is well above the
average across the products and there
are a few real outliers look at this
budget pasta up 50
and budget mince beef
up 16 not good news at all if spagbol is
one of your staples and some items have
fallen in price too look uh budget
potatoes down by 14 and cheese down by
seven percent but the reality still
holds that even if the items themselves
are rising at the same rate poorer
households will be hit harder by those
rises that's partly because those people
have less disposable income but it's
also because of this this shows the
population split up into 10 parts by
income and look the poorest at the
richest 10 over here they're
experiencing inflation about 7.9 but the
poorest 10th over here look much higher
experiencing inflation of around 11
this research also found there's a big
difference in cost between the lowest
value items and the next lowest cost
versions it really shows how careful
less well of shoppers are needing to be